I'm here on the streets of Hollywood to
find out the answer to one special
questions I'm just trying to figure
something out it was just wondering if
you could tell me the answer to one
question do you know if women poop I
don't think so no I've never seen it
happen
no women don't know of course not I
think it's one of those mysteries that
just never be solved an unsolved
I'd also love mystery like I gotta ask
you right now do you poop you give me
one or two answers what would yours be
yes okay so there you go that's one
person but here's what's confusing right
like I know that I take but then
everybody's like women don't poop and
I'm like where is this disconnect
happening you never know
why do you think people are going around
saying that women don't poop because
people probably think that like it's
gross for women to poop people don't
like to see woman like not necessarily
dirty but like we're supposed to be
ladylike not ladylike what about it is
unladylike being a human women are human
where do you think that originates from
fear misogyny big time definitely that I
think that this illusion that you speak
of should be a smash I think that we
should all be proud of that of what of
pooping OOP OOP OOP OOP OOP we have to
everybody poops
[Music]